good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we begin this show with
some shocking news lying has been
detected here in Washington mendacity
deceit duplicity Danis saying things
that aren't true the hair on my arms is
going up just telling you about this but
it happened and we can prove it now to
be clear news anchors didn't do it news
anchors don't lie they're good people
neither did professional cable news
commentators the one making millions on
the side as lobbyists for foreign
governments or big multinational
corporations commentators always tell
the truth and that's why they and their
scrupulously honest news anchor friends
are so utterly disgusted tonight
horrified really by what retired General
Michael Flynn has done watch they're
stunned reactions Michael Flynn lied to
the FBI
Flynn lied again and again and again two
FBI agents just lie lies lies and more
lies hold on for just a minute about
whose significant and who's not Flynn
lied the tone should be when you speak
to a prosecutor you speak to the truth
everybody lied Michael Flynn was
betraying his country Michael Flynn was
betraying his office he lied says Don
Lamanna and his news anchors friend lied
he's a very bad man a lying kind of man
the worst kind he could never work in
television for his crime of lying
Michael Flynn the liar may soon be
locked away in a Cell now we keep the
rest of us safe from his perfidious lies
that day can't come fast enough say the
news anchors cuff him America longs to
breathe free once more Michael Flynn
will be 60 years old next week the
Washington Post calculates he faces five
years in prison and let that be a
warning to all of us that's what happens
to people who lie in Washington or does
it from a golf course somewhere in Dubai
you could almost hear Bill Clinton
chuckling softly lied under oath still
making 300 grand a speech
not everyone faces the same penalties
for lying it turns out
Mark Zuckerberg came to Washington last
spring to talk about Facebook that's the
soul-destroying social media company
that has made him a multi billionaire
while in town Zuckerberg stopped by the
Congress where and he might want to ask
the kids to leave the room for this he
lied
yep don't tell Don LeMond but Mark
Zuckerberg is a liar watch him do it
this is the most important principle for
Facebook every piece of content that you
share on Facebook you own and you have
complete control over who sees it and
and how you share it and you can remove
it at any time are you willing to give
me more control over my data senator how
does someone who uses Facebook I believe
that you should have complete control
over your data yeah you have complete
control over your data you control who
sees it you own it that's really the
most important principle at Facebook
Mark Zuckerberg says so with a
completely straight face the only
problem it was a lie sorry kids
according to a piece in The New York
Times Facebook does not actually allow
you or anyone else to control your data
not at all in fact they secretly hand
over your data personal data to other
big tech companies now that decision has
made Mark Zuckerberg even richer adding
on to the house in Hawaii probably
unfortunately he's had to lie in the
process including to Congress and that's
a crime as Rob Speer once famously noted
you can't make an omelet without
breaking a few eggs in this case the
eggs are your privacy
apparently Facebook allowed Microsoft
search engine Bing to see the names of
your Facebook friends without telling
you about it Facebook also allowed
Netflix and Spotify to read your private
messages without telling you now there's
no evidence so far as of tonight that
Facebook has a video camera hidden in
your shower but close enough that's what
Mark Zuckerberg lied about not a small
lie really what did Mike Flynn lie about
well according to the FBI Flynn lied
about conversations he'd had with the
Russian ambassador kids lyac you
remember him Flynn said that he and his
lyac had never talked about expelling
Russian diplomats or about Russia voting
in the UN on symbolic resolutions and in
fact they had talked about both of those
things the feds already knew that
because they were listening in secretly
there was nothing improper about the
conversations that Flynn and kids lyac
had the crime was the lie it's always
the crime except as Mark Zuckerberg Mark
Zuckerberg can lie about something that
affects hundreds of millions of
Americans but it's not really a big deal
Zuckerberg is not looking at five years
in prison Zuckerberg will not be
sanctioned by Congress ever so what's
the difference well unlike Mike Flynn
Mark Zuckerberg is a hero to the
American news media
he's who they want to be he's richer
than God he went to Harvard he wears
t-shirts at work for real he's for open
borders all the cool people like Mark
Zuckerberg even in foreign countries for
example when the fascist government of
China was looking for new tools to
repress its own population you think
they would - Mike Flynn for help okay
I don't think so Flynn is tough on China
old-fashioned as he is but Mark
Zuckerberg by contrast was happy to help
as they say at McKinsey Mark Zuckerberg
gets it but wait what does Mike Flynn
ever done for anyone 33 years in uniform
that's not very innovative - lies told
by two high-profile Americans one is
going to prison in late middle age the
other will be available for like 40
years
for commencement addresses and awards
dinners held in his honor that's the
tale of Mike Flynn and Mark Zuckerberg
it tells you everything